qu'est-ce que tu as fait cette semaine
j'étais en jet non mais tais-toi
mon petit garçon finalement ça s'est pas
fait je suis restée à Paris j'attendais
ton appel pour qu'on aille déjeuner ça
c'est pas fait non
j'avais quelques petits rendez-vous pour
me remettre un petit peu dans le bain
parce que j'ai quand même vous dire un
truc avec toute l'affection que j'ai
pour elle mais quand même dire la vérité
la semaine dernière
c'est un peu Mère Teresa mais quand même
pour dire la vérité il y avait dans sa
loge un assistant alors qui assiste quoi
on sait pas un attaché de presse donc
c'est une maquilleuse un coiffeur enfin
on avait déplacé Madonna donc je me suis
dit que ça fait 5 ans que tu c'est pas
vrai tu mens
il y a la maquilleuse
avec son assistante
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai